I saw Mad Max fury road in 3d this
weekend and it absolutely blew my mind
best action movie I've seen in about 30
years the 3d was amazing it just
non-stop crazy action great political
commentary and social commentary it was
absolutely fantastic you guys should see
it but what I wanted to talk about was
San Andreas which is about the San
Andreas Fault here in California and a
massive earthquake and another all-out
destruction movie because I saw the
preview for it before Mad Max and it was
in 3d and it's pretty intense take a
look you need to get out because even
though it's happening here in California
you will feel it on the East Coast
so we've all seen these kinds of movies
I used to live in New York City or I
lived in New York City my entire life
until the last two years and every other
week there was some movie coming out
about our city being destroyed I was
also I lived there during 9/11 so I
actually lived through part of our city
being destroyed and I remember after
9/11 thinking like I'm sort of over
these movies like there's so many movies
where New York City gets destroyed by
aliens or monsters or earthquakes you
know day after tomorrow so then I moved
to LA two years ago and now I'm here and
I guess these disaster movies are
chasing me to LA because I was watching
that and I've been here for two years
and I've experienced maybe like four or
five little earthquakes you know a
little Rumble something like that and
not too bad fine but yeah we do live on
this massive massive fault line the San
Andreas Fault and watching that I kinda
I don't know if it has something to do
with the internet and that we're also
aware of disasters constantly an
apologist happen all the earthquakes and
tornadoes and tsunamis and Japan and now
we hear about nuclear waste that's
actually coming to our west coast
because of the Japanese earthquake the
tsunami two years ago all this crazy
stuff was making me when I was watching
this I was just thinking like I do not
want to see this movie because it's
starting to feel too real
yet I'll probably yeah I'll wait till
it's on TBS probably anyway what do you
guys think are you gonna see the movie
are you are you over the disaster epochs
what is it about us that makes us want
to destroy ourselves let us know in the
comments right now